now in this teaser we just saw
there were quite a number of comments on
a scene that was very interesting
it was a scene around 41 seconds into
the video and in it we see kong with a
battle axe and godzilla at the back
this sparked a huge debate in the
comment section where one side
says that godzilla and kong are teaming
up against mecha godzilla and the other
side
says that kong's act is just stuck on
the building and that godzilla is
sneaking
from behind hairy cheeks i will read the
many comments on it
and then make my own theory on what it
actually is so let's do this
dreamy zava says that 0 minutes 41
seconds
godzilla in the background at the site
thank you and
you have a very good eye now let's check
out the other commands
godzilla world says they both are
fighting together see the clip when kong
fails in hong kong battle in speed of
0.25
godzilla is standing behind kong richard
pankas does damage so it's true
in talks uno says yes at 0 41 seconds
darth vader dwight says no no no no
kong's axe is stuck in a building and
godzilla is about to sneak attack
puma ambaro says exactly kong is
obviously trying to get his
axe unstuck lol godzilla world says
now see clearly kong was fell from
forward and godzilla was standing behind
so
he was not attacking him and they both
were fighting and another monster
see clearly again in another command
thread
rafi for zufar says at 0.41 seconds why
is there another godzilla could that be
chad x replies looks like mechagodzilla
pushed them or something
sarcastic duck there's only one godzilla
not shot
frederick chopin godzilla is trying to
ambush him
about in 130 to me it looks like the one
pushing us to mecca
and the real one is coming to help kong
back there laris
salvian saya says no it's kong acts
stuck in building
and he says the same thing y t
i x r p g 3 d god
cool name bro true that comes stuck but
if you play at 0.25 you can back from
godzilla uh yeah okay
darth vader the white he comes back here
and says kong's axe is stuck in a
building dude
godzilla is about to sneak attack or
something yeah so moving on to another
one
john paul del rosario says at 0 40
seconds
see that scene right there kong's acting
stuck in a building maybe godzilla went
ultra instinct and dodged the attack
richard pankas says or maybe they are
joined to fight something
loris salvian cyrus says no darth vader
the white
no high budget says at 0 41 seconds is
that mandarin writing or japanese
beats me so much says
0 41 seconds oh look kong has a friend
to the left
king case is good one roder roy where
wherein bhargava says pause the video at
zero 41 seconds and then look closely in
the second window frame from left
rotor roy replies okay so mechagodzilla
versus godzilla it is
frederick chapman is trying to ambush
him vedan bargava
says yup i think the movie at some point
it will be but after watching more
carefully i think
what frederick said is correct and as it
appears that kong got his bellag stuck
in the building
roslan says 0 41 seconds come exe broken
a deep miller replies it still looks
fixed
decoy says 041 seconds notice godzilla's
behind calm and they are facing in the
same direction
proof that they are fighting together
against maybe mechagodzilla
and lorenzo bao replies to me it looks
like kong stuck his axe into a building
and godzilla is coming from behind
ga foster says um that's godzilla
ramming kong into a building
comic malayali says 0-41 seconds if you
look closer you can see godzilla and
kong teaming up
loris salvian sayer who he's he's in
every threat
no it's kong act stuck in the building
coming malaya leaves look look at the
left side of kong you can see godzilla
comes not fighting godzilla
edit he is fighting someone else mecca i
think darth vader the white
dude bring your glasses and look again
kong's axe is stuck in the building in
front of him and godzilla looks like
he is about to sneak attack him coming
malayalee says bring your glasses and
look again they are teaming up it's not
godzilla it's mecca and that attacks
kong
and look at the color of smoke when he
fell and a sudden change in color
oh it's red not godzilla's maker
godzilla now
kong site adam mikhail bin mohammed
kamaru zaman mo says 042 godzilla was
behind kong maybe godzilla tried to
sneak up
to come and they fight something hmm who
could it be
j ross make a godzilla just thinking
mechagodzilla was the one who pushed
kong and godzilla in the background is
watching
adam mikhail bin mohammed kamar zaman mo
says you're right farhad bhagas if you
see closer
comments try to get the bags from the
building the axe stuck in the building
and godzilla is sneaking from behind
kong
jira says okay thanks ds production dude
impossible that's only sneak level 100
if godzilla can sneak like that
what the [ __ ] is come gonna do true okay
last threat john carl bernard says
try to slow-mo the video in 0-41 seconds
when comb got hit and fighting someone
godzilla was in his back roaring
gagana pereira says i don't know much
about english grammar but it's spelled
as
hit abedin says not everyone has english
as their mother language so
yeah it's a big world loris salvian
science says no it's kong
acts stuck in the building loris you
deserve a medal
so what are the thoughts of mind cue
well we think that godzilla and com are
in fact fighting and it's
godzilla in the back trying to attack
kong while his
axe is stuck in the building it would be
too early in the night to introduce
mechagodzilla as they are both not worn
out and still
hyper and active and very energetic so
they can easily take out mechagodzilla
if he comes into the fray
so what we thinks that godzilla
definitely was not sneaking
maybe tried to attack godzilla got his
act stuck there and tried to take it out
so godzilla was
dodging the attack and he's now facing
and about to attack kong again
sorry to say mechagodzilla might not be
in that scene
anyway take care subscribe smash that
subscribe button and slap that
notification bell for regular updates
take care fam